well i know you probably get this
question a lot
because of who your father was um and
you know i'm going to ask it
so
you're talking about the republican
party do you
i mean this doesn't resemble the
republican party that your father was
the president of and the leader of do
you think your father would be welcome
in this republican party or how do you
think he would feel about it i don't
think he would care whether he was
welcome in this republican party he
would be appalled by this republican
party but let me say too that it doesn't
really matter what my father would think
my father is is gone what matters is
what we think and even more to the point
what we do
from now on you know this the country is
in crisis uh it's a serious crisis we're
facing waves of violence coming no
matter what happens
uh whether the republicans win in
november or whether they lose in
particular in november and and in 2024
there will be violence i i promise you
that the the you know the proud boys or
whatever they call themselves and those
you know loaf crappers or whoever uh
they're not done you know they've got a
bunch of followers they've got guns and
they plan to use them they've been
itching to use them for just so long now
you know and now they see their chance
they see that they somehow have some
weird permission to do this and they're
they're going to do it and we're going
to have to deal with that
well you know we saw the the
the ad from eric greitens who is running
he's the former disgraced governor uh
from missouri ran the ad and basically
of course former governor is still
distressed right right well he is a
disgrace for sure especially after this
ad because he he goes full on fascists
and and saying if you just like me i
will use the power of the military and
the government to come kick down your
door and not come after his political
enemies but dissidents inside their own
party which is a new thing that we're
seeing like well that isn't that's not
that's not normal that team normal is
not there anymore so david give us an
autocratic regime the first thing you do
is purge your own team of differences
right
then you go after the enemy once you've
consolidated your team with true
believers now you go after the democrats
yeah because no one can turn against you
then at that point
you